labor day the next holiday weekend
coming up governor sissellac says this
is not the time to let up on safety
guidelines
don't have a barbecue in your backyard
with 50 or 100 of your closest friends
where they're going to all congregate i
mean
try to keep your gathering small so as
many families get ready for the holiday
weekend health care
workers are now urging the public not to
relax on those safety steps like
mask wearing and hand washing eight news
now reporter kate houston spoke to a
local doctor
who says it does not take much for this
virus to spread
quickly labor day barbecues at the park
could look different this year as
doctors insist families continue to
follow safety precautions
to avoid a spike in covet 19 cases
normally labor day weekend is filled
with picnics parades and family
get-togethers
this year bustame tomi and his family
are airing on the side of caution
and not planning a large picnic like
they normally do
maybe with another family or two that's
about it not like
a group bbq a picnic but you've got like
20 families gathered together
doctors are urging others to distance as
well
noting an increase in cases after the
fourth of july
there was a definitely a bump in covet
19
cases after july 4
probably because of people getting
together
more more than they were before dr david
hart with mountain view hospital
tells me although they're doing okay
right now he doesn't want the hospital
to get overwhelmed because people are
not taking safety guidelines seriously
i understand that it would be really
hard to have people
come into your home and not hug them and
not do the normal things
not sharing out of the same salsa bowl
and things like that
ahead of the holiday weekend the
southern nevada health district is
stressing the importance of wearing a
face covering
remaining distance and staying home if
possible
kate houston 8 news now so the cdc does
have some new
in-depth guidelines for hosting a
gathering or cookout during the pandemic
it does suggest arranging chairs outside
to allow for social distancing
and also of course limiting the number
of people who are serving food
and also keeping a guest list just in
case you need to do any potential
contact tracing